So let's take the notion of constraints. Consider this cube again. You'll notice
this cube has junctions, and these junctions have different kind of shapes. For
example, this looks like a Y junction, this looks like an L junction,
this also looks like an L junction, it's just that this arm of the L is coming
in the other direction. This also looks like an L junction. This junction,
on the other hand, looks a little bit like a W junction. So,
junctions of various kinds. Here are the kind of junctions that can occur, in
the world of trihedral objects like cubes. Y junction, W junction, T junction,
L junction. We can say a little bit more about each of these junctions.
Let us look at the Y junction first. If we examine the various kinds of
Y junctions that get formed in the world of trihedral optics, then we find that
whenever there is a Y junction formed, then each of these lines
represents a fold, where a fold is a line where two surfaces meet.
Now, the important thing about this is. That if we can infer, that this is
a Y junction and that this line represents a fold, then an image that follows,
this line must also represent a fold, and this line must also represent a fold.
Actually I should tell you quickly, that in the world of trihedral objects.
Y junctions can have multiple kind of constraints. But right now,
let's just look at this one single constraint. So in the case of an L junction,
which has a shape like this, in the world of trihedral objects, an L junction
is characterized by this being a blade, and this being a blade, where a blade is
a line, well we cannot infer that two surfaces are getting connected with each
other. Again, the L-Constraint can actually have many more formulations. But
right now, we're keeping it simple just looking at one single constraint for
the L junction. Similarly, in the world of trihedral objects, one of the ways in
which a double junction gets characterized is through a blade,
fold, blade. In effect, we're defining a spatial grammar here, for
the world of trihedral objects. The equivalent of this, in case of grammar of
natural language sentences might be that a sentence can have a non phrase,
followed by their verb phrase, followed by a propositional phrase, and so on.
Given this set of very simple constraints for the world of trihedral objects,
let us see how these constraints actually can be propagated, to group edges and
to surfaces